I got involved some time ago because
Clive Stafford Smith forwarded me a
letter that show karma had written from
Guantanamo Bay where he quoted a few of
my lyrics from a song called hey you and
so I wrote him a letter and made a
little video and posted it and I've been
following the case quite closely ever
since so that's why I'm here outside the
US Embassy today to join in this protest
that this resident of our capital city
and has been incarcerated in Guantanamo
Bay for the last 13 years with no trial
never having been accused of anything
which is something that I as an
Englishman fundamentally opposed to
believing as I do in the rule of law and
Magna Carta from all those years ago
being something very close to my heart
and and also i might mention that both
my father and my grandfather died my
grandfather in the First World War my
father in the second world war fighting
for all the things that English people
inherently believe in and so to find
ourselves involved in any way at all
with this these kind of actions like the
incarceration of people for many many
years with no explanation at all is
deeply disturbing that's on your program
earlier today I saw oh no please
continue sorry broke in my ear then
keep going okay i was i was watching her
sky earlier today and I saw the two boys
who were very movingly talking about
their father and one of them 15 years
old and who remembers him just and the
other one that has never met his father
and and the thing that concerned the
most these these two young men is that
they can't get answers to the questions
that they desperately need answering
which is why is their father locked up
what is the reason so it's this state of
secrecy that we're all beginning to
slowly not get used to but increasingly
a poor and which is one of the things
that upsets me the most I could go on
and on and and I will if you give me the
time in this space but Chuck Rama main
thing is that schalke armor be restored
I was just going to say Chaka armor has
been cleared for release twice under two
different administrations of US
government yet he is still there you've
called this case and national disgrace
we did see David Cameron with Barack
Obama last month in the United States he
was pressing for Shekhar armas case to
be given priority yet we've been hearing
for the US defense secretary Chuck Hagel
said he's the file hasn't even been on
his desk yet that's yeah i saw that
Chuck Hagel I saw that earlier today
which is absolutely an abomination I
also saw earlier today some chap I'm I
don't mean to disrespect anybody but I
can't remember his name he sounded as if
he'd been to a British public school at
some point in his past and he seemed to
be espousing the notion that em these
are difficult times and that we're
fighting a war on terror and in
consequence Magna Carta and the right
that all human beings should have to a
fair trial in front of a jury of their
peers is no longer something that we can
apply and that the powers that be must
know things that are frightfully
important that we don't know because we
are only the people
and don't need to know the details of
what is going on behind the scenes but
in consequence the rule of law can be
tossed out of the window and people like
chaka armo can be left to rot in some
prison cells somewhere without anybody
even being allowed to ask the question
why what is it that this man has done
apart from having a the wrong sounding
name and being in the wrong place at the
wrong time I think it's absolutely
disgusting is his obvious otherwise I
wouldn't be standing here hitting the
cold and the rain outside the American
Embassy and this friday afternoon will
you have written to shock her armor and
we were hearing from his sons before
that they get the occasional skype call
with their father that's all the contact
they have and you are close to shikahr
Armas lawyer he's been there 13 years
now as a detainee mentally and
physically that must have taken a toll
on him what do you know about his state
at the moment I I don't think it's
possible for any of us who have not been
incarcerated tortured locked up in
solitary confinement beaten handcuffed
blindfolded chain made to kneel
confronted with the absolute disdain of
your guards for 13 years for me to even
begin to imagine what it must be like to
be a prisoner in Guantanamo is
impossible so I wouldn't even be
prepared to do it what I do know though
is this this pervasive political
atmosphere within which we all live I
live in the United States of America now
so I saw dick cheney interviewed on meet
the press about a month ago and when he
was doin he was confronted with the fact
that one of the detainees held by the
CIA and tortured after nine eleven died
undeterred they tortured this man to
death and Dick Cheney went so what you
know we live in difficult times so we
kill a few p innocent people you know
that's tough them's the breaks but we've
well
this near con philosophy is something
that all right minded people all over
the world need to bite with every ounce
of humanity that they have in their
bodies because it could easily be the
death of us all not just shock armor and
all those others who are being so
abominably treated but the rest of us it
is absolutely essential that we start
talking to each other that we disavow
ourselves from this us and them
mentality where we're the good guys and
they're the bad guys we have to start
speaking to one another across the walls
that exists between over national
boundaries and also ideological and
religious boundaries as well talk is the
only thing which will help us locking
people up and hooding them and behaving
as if we were part of the Spanish
Inquisition is not something that is
going to help us to a better future for
our children and their children in the
many years that we hope we all have to
come okay Roger Waters thank you very
much mean to preach No thank you very
much for talking to us here on Scotty's
passionately representing your part in
we stand with chaka and the protest
taking place outside the american
embassy today Roger Waters musician
thank you